i can't speak for for drew as to
you know his
uh his wants i think he wants to play
more and and i think that
shoot we saw him play at a high level
and
we just
you know
we'll discuss every player on the roster
himself included but i i don't
anticipate this
grandiose meeting or phone call
anytime soon we'll go through
uh
the numbers will go through the team and
and then try to do what's best for for
for the team as well
that's sean payton with the open air
outdoor end of season press conference i
don't think they had practice yesterday
it wasn't that odd
there's no practice today coach
wishful thinking i know sorry it didn't
work out but no practice today um in all
seriousness no they've got drew brees
unrestricted free agent teddy
bridgewater unrestricted free agent some
hill restricted free agent who someone
out there may be thinking hey if they're
going to pay drew brees again we'll go
grab taysom hill with an offer that the
saints can't or won't match they got a
decision to make peter and i think
taysom hill was the best player on the
field on sunday
look i think what they're going to do is
try to sign drew brees
to either a two or three year deal
that will pay him a lot of money and
make sure that if the saints have to get
rid of him let's say a year before his
time
that the cap hit is not going to cream
them okay and i think they will re-sign
taysom hill and i think they're gonna
have to let teddy bridgewater go they
got too many people they're gonna resign
add teddy bridgewater to the patriots
pile
you know or or add teddy bridgewater to
any number of teams at teddy bridgewater
you know if i'm the chicago bears i'm at
least investigating
i want a better alternative uh than
chase daniel as much as i like chase
daniel as a guy and as an emergency
player i don't like him as a six-game or
eight-game potential substitute when you
bench mitchell trubisky midway through
the season next year i'm not saying that
they will but i'm saying that if they do
teddy bridgewater is a fascinating
possibility for the patriots of tom
brady leaves he is very close to bill
parcells
and that's one of the reasons why
sean payton who is close to parcells has
teddy bridgewater and that could be a
connection that helps sell bill
belichick on it i mean bridgewater was
5-0 this year right you can't and and he
was on the cusp of becoming a breakout
star in 2016 when he suffered that
horrific knee injury in a practice right
before the start of the season they they
were ready to see him become something
special and we're going to be four years
removed from that and uh there's going
to be demand for these new orleans
quarterbacks peter it's just like
minnesota two years ago when they had
teddy bridgewater case keenum and sam
bradford all three became free agents
now again taysom hill is restricted but
the the saints have a decision to make
and maybe the decision is none of the
above like the vikings did
it could be no question about it mike
but i do think
that two of the three are coming back
three of the three are not
and i would be very surprised if the
saints did not bring brees back
now look it's possible his agent is tom
condon and tom condon is always a guy
who gets absolutely top dollar and i
don't even know what top dollar is right
now
especially on a shorter contract is top
dollar two-year 70 million i don't know
there has to be a choking point for the
saints but i do think that brees knows
that he should continue with sean payton
yeah absolutely given where he is
physically in his career and what peyton
has done for him but peyton's got a big
decision to make because i get the
feeling he's kind of ready to move on to
that next phase with taysom hill and
take some hill a hell of a weapon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports